problema 1 para hacer un menor o igual
que t menor o igual que 6 una partícula
se mueve a lo largo del eje x la
posición de la partícula x dt no está
dada explícitamente la velocidad de la
partícula está dada por esta ecuación
que tenemos aquí y la aceleración de la
partícula está dada por esta otra
ecuación enorme que tenemos acá de hecho
nos tenían que dar la aceleración porque
recuerden que la aceleración es la
primera derivada de la velocidad pero
así lo que no nos dan es la posición de
la partícula pero si nos dan en donde
inicia x0 es igual a 2 inciso a la
rapidez de la partícula está creciendo o
decreciendo en el tiempo de igual a 5.5
da la razón de tu respuesta lo primero
que me doy cuenta es que este problema
tiene dos conceptos que parecen ser
iguales velocidad y rapidez sin embargo
no lo son la velocidad por su parte es
una cantidad vectorial es decir tienen
magnitud y sentido mientras que la
rapidez es una cantidad escalar
solamente tiene magnitud para entender
bien este par de conceptos voy a poner
un ejemplo supongamos que la velocidad
valga menos 5 metros sobre segundo y
para no perder el hilo del problema voy
a suponer que estamos sobre el eje de
las equis bueno aquí hay dos cosas que
analizar la velocidad tiene una magnitud
de 5 metros sobre segundos esto es la
magnitud y la dirección está dada por el
signo este signo negativo me da la
dirección de mi partícula
ahora si yo tuviera en este mismo caso
mi rapidez como es una cantidad de
escalar solamente me va a decir 5 metros
sobre segundo es decir la rapidez no me
está diciendo si mi velocidad va hacia
la derecha o hacia la izquierda si mi
partícula va hacia la derecha o hacia la
izquierda
solamente me dice que va a 5 metros
sobre segundo y ya está si nosotros
tenemos muy en cuenta las diferencias
entre estos dos conceptos el inciso a va
a ser muy sencillo lo primero que voy a
hacer es calcular la aceleración en el
tiempo te iguala 5.5 segundos y esto lo
hago porque la aceleración es la tasa de
cambio de la velocidad esto me va a
ayudar a entender mejor las diferencias
entre velocidad y rapidez pues a
trabajar se ha dicho lo bueno es que
tenemos la calculadora
en los exámenes de cálculo nos dejan
usarla porque si quisiéramos hacer en la
aceleración en el tiempo 5.5 segundos a
mano no serían nada sencillo de resolver
así que vamos a sustituir me queda un
medio que es punto 5 que multiplica a el
elevado a la t entre 4 o sea 5.5 entre 4
y a esto lo tengo que multiplicar por el
coseno esto lo tengo que multiplicar por
el coseno de kossen o bien de 5.5 entre
4 de 5.5 entre 4 y esto es igual a
punto 38 47 no aquí hay algo raro esto
no me había salido la otra vez una vez
el punto 5 porque a la 5.5 por aquí está
el error ya ven aquí estaba el error no
no no no yo lo que quiero es el coseno
de el elevado al latente 4 o sea elevado
a las 5.5 esto dividido entre 4 cierro
un paréntesis y tengo que cerrar otro
paréntesis además otro paréntesis y
ahora si esto es igual a menos 1 punto
35 85 y lo voy a redondear a menos 1.36
porque no me interesan todos los
decimales lo que me interesa realmente
es fijarnos en el signo de la
aceleración la aceleración en el tiempo
5.5 segundos es negativa lo que me está
diciendo es que la velocidad está
decreciendo la velocidad está
decreciendo
y por lo tanto ustedes pueden decir que
acabamos pero no no hemos acabado
recuerden que no queremos saber si la
velocidad está decreciendo o creciendo
queremos saber si la rapidez es la que
está decreciendo o decreciendo la
rapidez y recuerden que la aceleración
es la tasa de cambio de la velocidad no
de la rapidez y bueno para respondernos
la pregunta que queremos resolver
entonces hay que fijarnos también en la
velocidad lo que sabemos es que la
velocidad está decreciendo pero no
sabemos qué pasa con la rapidez hay dos
escenarios posibles o que la velocidad
sea positiva si la velocidad es positiva
supongamos que va 5 metros por segundo
realmente el valor que le demos no
importa lo que importa es que la
velocidad está decreciendo y como la
velocidad está decreciendo eso quiere
decir que la velocidad y la rapidez
ambas están decreciendo esto es porque
la aceleración es negativa recuerden que
la aceleración negativa nos da una
velocidad que decrece y por lo tanto en
un caso positivo
ambas decrecen
el otro escenario es que nosotros
tengamos una velocidad negativa como
nosotros tenemos una velocidad negativa
y además está decreciendo entonces la
magnitud de la rapidez va a ser más
grande que la magnitud de la velocidad y
como la rapidez es una cantidad de
escalar entonces no importa el signo si
es positivo o negativo en este caso la
rapidez estaría aumentando por lo tanto
no queda de otra lo que tenemos que
hacer es calcular cuál es la velocidad
en el tiempo 5.5 segundos entonces vamos
a hacerlo utilizamos la calculadora para
hacerlo en un tiempo un poco más corto y
ahora si es dos veces el seno dos veces
el seno de uno no lo voy a poner mejor
de otra manera voy a poner aquí que
están multiplicando y voy a poner
paréntesis para que no nos confundamos
otra vez dos veces mejor lo voy a poner
así dos veces el seno voy a abrir otra
vez paréntesis de elevado a las 5.5
entre 4 cierro un paréntesis
cierro otro paréntesis y
también que seré otro paréntesis ya esto
hay que sumarle 1 y ahora si la
velocidad en el tiempo 5.5 segundos es
negativa y si aproximamos era cercana a
menos 0.45 metros sobre segundo la
velocidad en este caso es negativa y si
tenemos una velocidad que es negativa y
además que está decreciendo porque la
aceleración también era negativa estamos
en el segundo escenario entonces si
empezamos con una velocidad negativa es
decir nos movemos hacia el lado
izquierdo esa velocidad seguirá
decreciendo mientras transcurra el
tiempo es decir se hará más y más y más
negativa ahora bien si la velocidad se
hace cada vez más negativa eso quiere
decir que su magnitud está aumentando y
si la magnitud está aumentando pues la
rapidez está aumentando que es la
respuesta que queríamos que interesante
acaso la velocidad está disminuyendo y
la rapidez está aumentando entonces
vamos a escribirlo la rapidez
aumentando
y bueno para justificar esta respuesta
podríamos decir lo siguiente fijémonos
en la aceleración en el tiempo 5.5
segundos es positiva o negativa es
negativa por lo tanto la velocidad está
decreciendo ahora hay que fijarnos en la
velocidad en el tiempo 5.5 segundos pues
también es negativa por lo tanto tengo
una velocidad que es negativa y que cada
vez se hace más negativa lo que me dice
que su magnitud está aumentando y la
rapidez también